we got our pizza pass for today we got
stamps on sample stamps what's up guys I
know Lisa I'm new to the city but
there's two things I know New York has a
lot of pizza in New York has a lot of
culture so I'm gonna go ask my friend
Eric if he wants to go we had like this
thing it's called it's called
oh my god she did her research in Russia
we have this thing called hot chick for
you which is just like pita stuffed with
cheese which is really good you don't
even have to melt the cheese
it's beats the time and she just brought
me to carrier today we got a starter is
called the okonomiyaki is like a
Japanese pancake we have like what we
call the Osaka style Japanese or open a
Miyagi a lot of people know as Japanese
pizza but we call the pancake
Cheerilee ready I've never had this like
combination of players in my mouth at
once being spirit guides at all
putting my tongue at different times
I don't know how to describe you cleaned
it up and I think the itis is like you
know if you eat a good ass meal just
kind of like I need a bed I know hon
tinnitus that's not anything near what
this is no
so where we going next we're going to
Germany Germany we had via host NYC a
mother we're gonna have to address a
frank Oakland which is basically German
style fits here she comes
I love the little you see the little
little white piece that's for the Jewish
boy probably cheers it cross all right
yeah I'm sorry the bacon is amazing I'm
not getting any beer today I'm not
getting any bacon a try-catch ingredient
separately review it onion that's a 10
ounce I know you adjust the cross and
nothing on it it's like a perfectly made
crack while you're doing that I'm gonna
have another piece I'm just gonna try
and cheese lick it off I don't know what
it is but so far so good
there's no cheese it's sour cream I told
you they're using sour cream and it did
not tell me that I told you he doesn't
cheese once you go sour cream they never
go back I'm not really a bingo I like
that that was like snack yeah yeah yeah
it was like kind of it was light and now
we get a stick
and last but not least we've got Brazil
[Music]
South the other way is Brazilian
pizzeria in New York
it's called pradhana PD which means like
chicken and a Brazilian homemade cream
cheese that we make here Portuguese a
pizza is the most popular topping in
Brazil okay let's try hmm I can't tell
if it's because I'm so happy about this
pizza or if it's this soda that's got me
feeling right oh you having Brazil for
their soccer but now I know them for
their pizza yeah sure people are very
happy about the Nutella pizza with
strawberry dessert pizza time
I don't remember last time I just happy
final thoughts alright Eric you're back
in Manhattan so tell me what did you
think I didn't even think you could make
pizza anything but just like cheese and
dough there was so many like unique
toppings honestly they were all Pizza
combinations I never knew anything
that's a really great but now I can
never go back
that Nutella pizza was the best thing
I've ever tried in my life like the good
thing about that pizza is like it could
be breakfast pizza lunch pizza dinner
pizza midnight Pizza snack in the middle
of the night pizza it was an experience
and I'm glad we experienced it together
repeat somebody's but I will say that
you're probably gonna find me passed out
to an office
[Music]